das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat jetzt der
bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
frau präsidentin für hat der abgeordnete
meine damen und herren bei
der bundestagswahl am 26 september hat
sich die mehrheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes für aufbruch und
fortschritt entschieden
der aufbruch soll gelingen werden noch
die korona pandemie unsere ganze
aufmerksamkeit und kraft erfordert aber
umso wichtiger ist es jetzt nicht zu
zögern es gibt viel zu tun für
uns liegen große aufgaben und
entscheidende weichenstellung
weichenstellungen die wir jetzt
vornehmen weil wir jetzt den richtigen
zirkus in die zukunft einschlagen müssen
wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren
meine damen und herren das gilt
zuallererst für den kampf gegen die
korona pandemie die neue bundesregierung
übernimmt den staffelstab in
außergewöhnlich bedrückenden machen
dezember das sind ohnehin die dunkelsten
und kürzesten tage des jahres das
schlägt aufs gemüt
aber dezember bedeutet sonst immer auch
adventszeit das ist die zeit in der wir
normalerweise stimmungsvolle
weihnachtsmärkte erleben gemütliche
stunden mit familie freunden und
bekannten am glühweinstand gesellige
weihnachtsfeiern im kreis von kollegen
und vereinskameraden
in diesem jahr ist das anders
jetzt schon zum zweiten mal
die bürgerinnen und bürger verfolgen
abend für abend auf ihren bildschirm die
entwicklung der korona pandemie viel zu
hohe infektionsraten erschöpfte
ärztinnen und krankenpfleger dramatische
verlegungen von intensivpatienten per
flugzeug und hubschrauber
schlangen vor impfzentren die sorge vor
der neuesten variante des virus
mir ist bewusst in diesen tagen fällt es
manchmal schwer den mut nicht zu
verlieren
ich weiß dass abstand halten und
glücklich seien sehr schlecht zusammen
passen dass viele unserer unter
einsamkeit leiden dass endlich mal damit
schluss sein müsste dass es wieder los
gehen müsste das leben und die
unbeschwertheit
niemanden geht es richtig gut in diesen
zeiten mir nicht ihnen nicht den
bürgerinnen und bürgern nicht und viele
fragen sich geht das jetzt immer so
weiter oder wird es wieder besser heute
sage ich den bürgerinnen und bürgern
unseres landes ja es wird wieder besser
ja wir werden den kampf gegen diese
pandemie mit der größten
entschlossenheit führen und ja wir
werden diesen kampf gewinnen wir werden
die krise vin
die lage ist schwer aber die lösung
nicht auf der hand nach 20 monaten
pandemie wissen wir längst das virus mag
viele kontakte und verbreitet sich
darüber rasend schnell
darum war das oberste gebot dem letzten
langen winter kontakte zu reduzieren in
diesem winter sind wir etwas weiter
jeder kann und sollte sich regelmäßig
testen wir alle sollten unsere kontakte
weiter behutsamen einschränken aber am
allerwichtigsten ist jeder kann und
sollte sich impfen lassen
darum geht es mir deshalb habe ich uns
ende november ein ehrgeiziges zwischen
ziel gesetzt ich möchte dass wir alle
zusammen in deutschland 30 millionen
impfdosen bis jahresende in die oberarme
kriegen als erste impfung als zweite
impfung und als booster empfohlen
so kriegen wir sind die vierte welle
hinter uns zu lassen heute kann ich
sagen wir haben bereits 19 millionen
millionen impfungen erreicht wir sind
auf dem richtigen weg wenn wir mit aller
kraft weitermachen werden wir die 30
millionen bis jahresende auch erreichen
meine dringende bitte ist
wie wir bürgerinnen und bürger machen
sie alle mit dann schaffen wir die 30
millionen und dann sind wir am ende
dieses monats diesen einen
entscheidenden schritt vorangekommen
es ist mir wichtig dass wir es weiter
gemeinsam angehen dass wir uns weiter
unterhalten und so kroner besiegen
deshalb habe ich ein krisenstab
aufgebaut der aus dem kanzleramt heraus
jeden tag neu die lage bewertet und auch
handelt er wird von einem erfahrenen
general geleitet und wir haben experten
zusammen gerufen die die regierung
ständig beraten
deshalb erhöhen wir die kapazitäten der
impfzentren deutlich deshalb sind mobile
teams in stadt und land unterwegs
deshalb beziehen wir jetzt auch
zahnarztpraxen und apotheken mit ein
deshalb sagen wir jetzt es ist sehr
wichtig dass alle dreifach geimpft sind
wir werden weiter kämpfen und noch mehr
boostern um die verbreitung des virus zu
erschweren
die pandemie die epidemie ist global
deshalb engagieren wir uns international
für impfstoffe in den armen ländern und
auch in europa werden wir gemeinsam
handeln schon morgen werden wir zum
europäischen rat intensiv mit der krone
lage in europa beschäftigen
wir werden alles tun was notwendig ist
es gibt dafür die bundesregierung keine
roten linien die bundesregierung wird
nicht einen einzigen augenblick ruhen
und wir werden jeden nur möglichen hebel
bewegen bis wir alle unser früheres
leben und alle unsere freiheiten
zurückgekommen war
dass die notwendigen maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden das ist meine aufgabe
dafür trage ich die verantwortung und
das hat meine oberste priorität
und da haben hier nochmals meine
inständige bitte an sie alle an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger helfen sie mit
dieser aufgabe zu bewältigen helfen sie
uns allen vermeidbares leid zu
verhindern lassen sie sich impfen
schützen sie ihr leben und das leben der
anderen
zur wahrheit dieser pandemie gehört aber
auch heute im dezember 2021 könnte jede
und jeder erwachsene in deutschland
längst zweifach geimpft sein
mindestens alle besonders gefährdeten
bürgern und bürger könnten gewiss sein
dann hätten wir die pandemie jetzt im
griff dann würden wir alle jetzt mit
unseren alten freiheiten und unseren
familien und freunden eine besinnliche
vorweihnachtszeit erlebten die kraft des
wissenschaftlichen fortschritts hätte
uns genau das ermöglicht und darum
verstehe ich auch den unmut vieler
bürgerinnen und bürgern das sind ja die
die in der zeit der pandemie immer
vorsichtig gewesen sind die alles
richtig gemacht haben die sich an alle
regeln gehalten haben die doppelt und
dreifach geimpft sind sie haben alles
dafür getan dass wir unser früheres
leben und unsere frühere freiheit zurück
bekommen ihnen allen danke im namen der
gesamten bundesregierung von herzen
und danke ausdrücklich auch den
bundesländern ihren
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten für die enge und
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit in dieser
schwierigen zeit
allen verspreche ich diese
bundesregierung wird immer fest an ihrer
seite stehen sie wird immer an der seite
derjenigen in unserem land stehen die
sich solidarisch verhalten an der seite
derjenigen die mit ihrer vorsicht und
ihrer rücksichtnahme den zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft möglich machen
aber was es eben heute auch gibt in
deutschland das es wirklichkeit
verleugnung das sind absurde
verschwörungs geschichten mutwillige
desinformation und
gewaltbereiten extremismus
um es klar zu sagen eine kleine
extremistische minderheit in unserem
land hat sich von unserer gesellschaft
unserer demokratie unserem gemeinwesen
und unserem staat abgewandt nicht nur
von wissenschaft rationalität und
vernunft
für die gesamte bundesregierung sage ich
wir haben respekt vor ernst gemeinten
einwenden wir hören zu wir suchen die
debatte wir sind offen für kritik und
widerspruch
wir geben auch den versuch nicht auf
bislang noch zurückhaltende davon zu
überzeugen dass sie sich doch impfen
lassen mit der kraft der fakten der
kraft der vernunft oder der kraft des
besseren arguments
aber genauso klar ist wir werden es uns
nicht gefallen lassen dass eine winzige
minderheit von enthemmten extremisten
versucht unserer gesamten gesellschaft
ihren wild aufzutreten
diese winzigen minderheit der
hasserfüllten die mit fackel menschen
mit gewalt und morddrohungen und alle
angreift werden wir mit allen mitteln
unseres demokratischen rechtsstaats
entgegentreten unsere demokratie ist
eine wehrhafte demokratie
viel ist ja zurzeit von der angeblichen
spaltung unserer gesellschaft die rede
dazu stelle ich fest unsere gesellschaft
ist nicht gespalten
die überwältigende mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem land
verhält sich solidarisch vernünftig und
vorsichtig die bundesregierung ist die
regierung dieser überwältigenden
mehrheit sie ist die regierung an einer
solidarischen vernünftigen und
vorsichtigen bürgerinnen und bürger in
unserem land und sie ist ausdrücklich
auch die regierung derjenigen
bürgerinnen und bürger die noch zweifel
haben oder vielleicht ganz einfach noch
nicht dazu gekommen sind sich impfen zu
lassen die regierung ist die regierung
der bürgerinnen und bürger die sich an
die regeln halten und die umgekehrt
erwarten dass ihr staat sie in notlagen
beschützt und ihre freiheit sichern
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ausdrücklich danke ich und gerade an
dieser stelle der bisherigen
bundeskanzlerin frau dr merkel hat der
bundesrepublik deutschland 16 jahre lang
in eindrucksvoller weise als
bundeskanzlerin gedient jederzeit
orientiert an der sache und an den
tatsachen stets völlig uneitel und ohne
allüren immer mit mut und mit klugheit
mit pragmatismus und mit umsicht
in den wochen des regierungswechsels
mitten in dieser schwierigen zeit der
pandemie hat bundeskanzlerin merkel
alles nur mögliche getan um die
staffelübergabe an ihren nachfolger so
reibungslos wie nur irgend möglich zu
gestalten
die unaufgeregte
demokratische zivilität des übergangs
von der einen bundesregierung zur
nächsten bundesregierung wurde weltweit
mit viel bewunderung und respekt
aufgenommen
auch hier genauso wie für die
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit und
kollegialität in den vergangenen jahren
sage ich danke frau dr
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die neue bundesregierung wird unser land
in dieser wahlperiode zielstrebig auf
die kommenden jahrzehnte vorbereitet
ein modernes deutschland jederzeit auf
der höhe der herausforderungen unseres
jahrhunderts das ist das ziel das ist
die aufgabe die wir ab sofort anpacken
die bundesregierung die jetzt unter
meiner führung ihrer arbeit aufnimmt
wird eine fortschritts regierung sein
wir sind eine regierung des technischen
fortschritts weil wir nur mit
technischen fortschritt klimaneutral
werden können und weil deutschland und
europa nur so mithalten können im
globalen wettbewerb wir sind eine
regierung des sozialen fortschritts bei
respekt gerechtigkeit und lebenschancen
für alle eben keinen gegensatz zu sind
zu wirtschaftlicher stärke sondern deren
voraussetzung
und wir sind eine regierung des
gesellschaftlichen und des kulturellen
fortschritt die gesetz und recht an die
lebenswirklichkeit unseres vielfältigen
landes anpasst
kraft des fortschritts jetzt in der
korona pandemie erleben wir sie doch
gerade wieder den m rna impfstoff haben
übersah ihn und hier bei uns in
deutschland erdacht und entwickelt nicht
zuletzt ihnen und ihren bahnbrechenden
impfstoff verdanken wir es dass diese
pandemie nicht noch um ein vielfaches
verheerender finden konnte
es ist keine übertreibung
diese beiden forscher aus mainz am
millionen von menschen auf der ganzen
welt das leben gerettet ihr impfstoff
ist der beste beweis dafür dass kluger
fortschritt kluge innovation und kluge
modernisierung die welt besser machen
darum
darum setzen wir auf die kraft und auf
die möglichkeit des fortschritts und
zwar gerade jetzt in dieser zeit
wir brauchen fortschritt denn die
aufgaben die vor uns liegen sind
riesengroß
die klimakrise erfordert entschlossenes
systematisches und international
abgestimmtes vorgehen
die menschengemachte erderwärmung muss
gestoppt werden die pariser klimaziele
gelten
hinter uns liegen 250 jahre in denen
unser wohlstand auf dem verbrennen von
kohle öl und gas begründete jetzt liegen
vor uns etwa 23 jahre in denen wir aus
den fossilen brennstoffen aussteigen
müssen und aussteigen werden denn wir
haben uns verpflichtet bis 2045 muss
deutschland klimaneutral sein
damit liegt vor uns die größte
transformation unserer industrie und
ökonomie seit mindestens 100 jahren
hinzu kommen die herausforderung der
globalisierung und digitalisierung
beide prozesse haben die welt verändert
neue lebenschancen und neuen wohlstand
gebracht auch bei uns in deutschland
aber zugleich macht die schiere dynamik
der entwicklung fielen hier in unserem
land auch sorgen sie fragen sich geht
das alles gut aus für mich für meine
familie für meine kinder in zehn zwanzig
dreißig jahren wird es in zukunft noch
gut bezahlte arbeit sichere renten und
ein gutes gesundheitssystem geben für
leute wie mich
was kommt dazu auf die stadt auf die
region in der ich lebe
das sind alles große herausforderung und
es sind nicht die einzigen
allen muss klar sein die vor uns
liegenden 20er jahre werden jahre der
veränderung der erneuerung und des
umbaus seien alle in unserem land wissen
dass wir brauchen diese erneuerung aber
zugleich wollen wir dass diese
erneuerung allen bürgerinnen und bürgern
in unserem land zugute kommt das ist
unser versprechen wir werden neue
sicherheit durch wandel schaffen und
werteten sie für sicherheit im wandel
sorgen
natürlich reform veränderung fortschritt
dass es niemals selbstzweck mit der
angeblichen notwendigkeit des
fortschritts runde in der vergangenheit
immer wieder auch problematische
entwicklungen begründet die ökologischen
krise mit denen wir es heute weltweit zu
tun haben sind nicht zuletzt auch folgen
früherer vorstellung von fortschritt
manche entwicklung wurden zu ihrer zeit
als großer fortschritt gefeiert im
rückblick sehen wir sie aber kritisch
denken wir an die vorstellung von der
autogerechten stadt denken wir an die
atomenergie oder bestimmte form der
industriellen landwirtschaft
aber damit ist doch nicht die idee des
fortschritts selbst widerlegt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert brauchen
wir nicht weniger fortschritt sondern
mehr fortschritt
aber wir brauchen besseren fortschritt
wir brauchen klugen fortschritt
fortschritt für eine bessere welt für
ein besseres land für eine bessere
gesellschaft für mehr freiheit für jede
einzelne bürgerin und jeden einzelnen
bürger das ist der fortschritt den wir
wollen
diesen weg des fortschritts der
erneuerung und transformation wird die
neue bundesregierung auf allen ebenen
konsequent einschlagen unser wohlstand
unsere
lebensqualität und die arbeitsplätze des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts hängen
davon ab dass uns diese modernisierung
gelingt und darum fangen wir jetzt an
dabei wissen wir veränderung fällt
schwer aufbruch ist nicht einfach
im internationalen vergleich ist
deutschland ein stark ist ein
erfolgreiches seien sehr wohlhabendes
land gute ideen hochwertige produkte und
verfahren haben den aufstieg unseres
landes zu einer der weltweit führenden
industrienationen begründet made in
germany das ist seit über 100 jahren
weltweit ein gütesiegel und gerade darum
ist die versuchung manchmal ein bisschen
groß weiter auf die schon vorhandenen
erfolgsrezepte zu setzen es ist ja immer
verlockend bislang erfolgreiches einfach
weiterzumachen
kaiservilla mit dem zweiten wird das
zitat zugeschrieben
ich glaube an das pferd das automobil
ist eine vorübergehende erscheinung
das war ein irrtum
hätte sich diese sichtweise seinerzeit
durchgesetzt dann wäre deutschland heute
ein anderes land ein engeres land ein
rückständiges land
darum werden wir in deutschland neue
wege einschlagen auch das bestehende auf
den ersten blick noch oft gut
funktioniert heute ist deutschland ein
starkes land aber gerade darum muss uns
jetzt der aufbruch gelingen gerade jetzt
müssen wir handeln darum will die
regierung mehr fortschritt wagner
ja es ist ein wagnis von bewährten
rezepten abzukehren es ist ein wagnis
aufzubrechen und den weg der veränderung
einzuschlagen aber dieses wagnis müssen
wir eingehen denn waidhaus waghalsiger
als aufbruch und fortschritt denn jetzt
stillstand und weitersuchen es geht
nicht wenig um weniger als die
lebensbedingungen heutiger und
zukünftiger generationen auf der erde es
geht um den zukunft von wohlstand und
arbeitsplätzen hier bei uns in
deutschland darum müssen wir den
aufbruch hinbekommen und das werden wir
auch wenn wir uns auf unsere stärken
konzentrieren wenn wir auf unseren
erfolgen aufbauen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
eine der großen stärken unseres landes
und auch eine der wichtigsten
voraussetzungen unseres wirtschaftlichen
erfolgs war immer unser
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt nicht
erst in der korona pandemie spüren nein
erleben viele bürgerinnen und bürger
dieser innere zusammenhalt diese
gesellschaftliche solidarität ist
gefährdet
mein leitbild das leitbild der neuen
bundesregierung in dieser lage ist eine
gesellschaft des respekts
respekt anerkennung 8 das bedeutet dass
wir uns bei aller verschiedenheit
gegenseitig als gleiche unter gleichen
wahnsinnigen respekt heißt niemand
schaut auf andere herab weil er oder sie
sich für stärker hält für gebildete für
reiche damit allein werden wir schon ein
großes stück weiter
denn viele der verletzungen und
kränkungen in unserer gesellschaft haben
ihre ursache darin dass sich bürgerinnen
und bürger nicht genügend wahrgenommen
für
aber wenn uns die korona pandemie eines
gelehrt hat dann doch dies es gibt keine
höherwertigen und minderwertigen
tätigkeiten in unserem land
kassiererin oder krankenpfleger
reinigungskräfte paketboten oder bahn
schaffnerin sie alle leisten ihren
unverzichtbaren beitrag zu unserem
gemeinwesen hat mit essen
administrative akademische oder
künstlerische tätigkeit sind keine
besseren oder würdigeren tätigkeiten sie
sind andere tätigkeiten auch sie
verdienen natürlich respekt
mehr augenhöhe und weniger herablassung
das ist das eine wenn wir eine
gesellschaft des respekts wollen das
andere ist eine tatkräftige politik für
mehr respekt und das wird die
bundesregierung leisten denn applaus für
krankenpflegerin oder das trinkgeld für
den paketboten das ist gut und richtig
aber das reicht nicht wir brauchen eine
aktive politik die respekt ermöglicht
respekt bewahrt und immer wieder
erneuert und dabei geht es um harte
materielle soziale und ökonomische
fragen
niedrige löhne für anstrengende arbeit
prekäre beschäftigung ohne tarifvertrag
armut im alter
wohnungsmangel und explodierende mieten
fehlenden lebensperspektiven in manchen
ländlichen regionen nicht zuletzt in
ostdeutschland in solchen mißständen
kommt aus sicht der betroffenen oft
fehlender respekt vor ihrer leistung und
ihrer anstrengung zum ausdruck
missstände wie diese sind deshalb gift
für unseren zusammenhalt darum werden
wir sie beheben und wir fangen jetzt
damit an
da es auch zu jeder politik des respekts
gehört dass sie sich konsequent gegen
rassismus sexismus und jede andere
diskriminierung richtet hier werden wir
nicht nachlassen auch vom weiteren
fortschritt in diesen fragen hängt der
zusammenhalt unserer gesellschaft ab
und gerade auch im kontext unserer
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger mit nicht
deutschen wurzeln ist der begriff des
respekts besonders wichtig millionen von
ihnen sind hier geboren viele familien
leben schon seit generationen in
deutschland ihre eltern und großeltern
haben als sogenannte gastarbeiter massiv
zum aufbauen wohlstand unseres landes
beigetragen
wir sprechen hier von fast einem viertel
unserer bevölkerung sie haben anspruch
auf volle teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen
leben in diesem land
wir sind ein einwanderungsland um einen
begriff unseres bundespräsidenten
aufzugreifen ein land mit
migrationshintergrund aber
wir müssen ein noch besseres
integrationsland werden dafür fühle ich
mich verantworten
und alle die sich hier bei uns in
deutschland für ihre persönliche zukunft
anstrengen haben mich und die
bundesregierung auf ihrer seite
meine damen und herren diese konkreten
aufgaben mit einer politik des respekts
anzugehen das ist auch wichtig um das
soziale vertrauen in unseren land zu
stärken das vertrauen in die demokratie
und ihre institution
die bürgerinnen und bürger gerade
besonders die schutzbedürftigen unter
ihnen erwarten von ihrem staat dass er
sie so gut wie möglich vor krisen und
deren folgen schützt und im staat dies
nicht gelungen ist da muss er für die
zukunft lernen das wird eine der großen
politischen aufgaben der nächsten jahre
und dazu gehört auch dass wir das was
wir globalisierung nennen so angehen
dass diese entwicklung unserer
gesellschaft licht in lager spaltet wenn
wir dem gefährlichen trend der
renationalisierung etwas entgegensetzen
wollen dann darf nicht der eindruck
entstehen die globalisierung seit der
demokratischen kontrolle entglitten
darum wird diese bundesregierung
konkrete politische initiativen
vorantreiben die deutlich machen wir
können eine gerechtere globalisierung
durchsetzen am projekt an der
internationalen mindestbesteuerung zum
beispiel beteiligen sich inzwischen
137 staaten das ist nicht nur aus
fiskalischen gründen ein wichtiges
andere holen sondern gerade auch deshalb
weil es die gerechtigkeit und das
vertrauen in die demokratie stärkt
um es klar zu sagen die frage nach den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt ist
keine frage der wir uns erst dann zu
wenden müssten wenn wir irgendwann alle
anderen großen probleme gelöst haben von
der pandemie über die industrielle
transformation bis zur klimaneutralität
es ist genau umgekehrt die großen
probleme unserer zeit werden wir
überhaupt nur dann bewältigen wenn wir
uns unterwegs nicht der zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft abhanden kommt
soziales vertrauen und sozialer
zusammenhalt zu organisieren das ist die
voraussetzung schlechthin dafür dass
deutschland in diesem jahrhundert eine
gute zukunft haben wird gelingen wird
uns das nur mit einer politik des
respekts einer politik die immer alle
bürgern und bürger im blick behält
meine damen und herren in der tat wir
haben große aufgaben vor uns deutschland
muss und deutschland wird in den 2020er
jahren den aufbruch hin zu einer
klimaneutralen und digitalisierten
gesellschaft vollziehen die
bundesregierung wird die arbeit
aufnehmen damit deutschland gestärkt aus
diesem wandel hervorgeht damit das leben
der bürgerinnen und bürger besser wird
damit unsere wirtschaft prosperiert und
viele gut bezahlte neue arbeitsplätze
entstehen
die kommenden vier jahre werden wir auch
dafür nutzen deutschland strukturell fit
zu machen für die welt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts damit die
transformation gelingt brauchen wir eine
moderne verwaltung die den wandel voran
treibt statt ihn zu verzögern es geht um
technische und gesellschaftliche
innovation es geht um milliardenschwere
investitionen in neue wohnung
schienenwege ladesäulen
offshore-windparks pv-anlagen stromnetze
und vieles vieles mehr es geht darum die
fundamente für ein neues technologisches
zeitalter zulegen von der wasserstoff
pipeline über die dezentrale
stromversorgung bis hin zur elektro
ladesäule darum werden wir in
jahrzehnten der zukunftsinvestitionen
einläuten
der größte teil dieser investition wird
privatwirtschaftlich erbracht werden die
regierung wird sicherstellen dass die
rahmenbedingungen dafür stimmen wir
werden langfristig verlässliche politik
machen die im dialog mit unternehmen und
beschäftigten steht und klare
orientierung bietet wo es möglich ist
werden wir marktmechanismen nutzen etwa
einen starken europäischen
emissionshandel wo es nötig ist werden
wir das ordnungsrecht einsetzen zb bei
der klimafreundlichkeit von gebäuden und
wo es sinnvoll ist werden wir
förderprogramme schaffen um anfangs
höhere preise neuer technologien
auszugleichen und investitionen in
klimafreundliche technologie zu
unterstützen
deshalb werden wir eine super
abschreibung für klimaschutz und
digitale wirtschaftsgüter schaffen
diese investitions prämie wird es in den
jahren 22 und 23 möglich machen einen
anteil der kosten der im jeweiligen jahr
angeschafften oder hergestellten
wirtschaftsgüter des anlagevermögens vom
steuerlichen gewinn abzuziehen und
zusätzlich werden diese wirtschaftsgüter
entsprechend ihrer nutzungsdauer linear
abgeschrieben von dieser super
abschreibung profitieren somit alle die
in besonderer weise in klimaschutz und
digitalisierung investieren
außerdem werden wir die in der korona
krise ausgeweitete möglichkeit
verlängern und erweitern das
unternehmerische verluste bei der
berechnung von steuerzahlen rück rücken
stärker berücksichtigt werden können
auch das schafft finanziellen spielraum
für unternehmen
ein wichtiger treiber für innovationen
und investitionen sind start ups wir
werden das potenzial das von solchen
innovativen unternehmens ideen für die
transformation ausgeht stärker nutzen
und unser land zum führenden startup
standort in deutschland machen
auch die rolle der kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau bei der finanzierung von
start ups werden wir ausbauen und wir
verbessern die steuerlichen bedingungen
wenn mitarbeiter sich an ihren
unternehmen beteiligen gerade für
startups ist es eine wichtige maßnahme
damit die transformation unseres landes
gelingt wird die bundesregierung in den
kommenden vier jahren viele milliarden
euro einsetzen müssen dafür werden wir
den verfassungsgemäß zulässigen
spielraum nutzen ein wichtiger kern für
diese zukunftsinvestition ist der
energie- und klimafonds den wir zu einem
klima und transformation sfo ausweiten
und besser ausstatten werden
zugleich kommt es jetzt darauf an dass
wir genau überprüfen auf welche ausgaben
wir natürlich verzichten können und wo
dem staat einnahmen vorenthalten werden
darum wird die bundesregierung den kampf
gegen steuerhinterziehung und steuer
umgehen weiter voranbringen und weltweit
eine vorreiterrolle übernimmt
die steuerung geht weiter erschweren
diejenigen die für sich selbst und ihre
kundinnen und kunden steuertricks
entwickeln und vermarkten müssen diese
den zuständigen behörden jetzt auch für
rein nationale fälle melden so kann dann
der gesetzgeber schnell auf neue
umgehungsmöglichkeiten reagieren deshalb
werden wir die bereits eingeführte
mitteilungspflicht für
grenzüberschreitende steuergestaltung
auch auf nationale steuergestaltung für
unternehmen mit einem umsatz von mehr
als zehn millionen euro ausweiten
trotzdem insgesamt gilt für die
haushaltspolitik der kommenden jahre
nicht alles was wünschenswert ist wird
sofort machbar sein die notwendigen
maßnahmen zur bewältigung der
transformation können und werden wir
aber sicher finanzieren
und auch das ist nicht neue finanz
spielräume entstehen durch wachstum
wachstum wiederum ist das ergebnis
kluger investition und darum war und ist
es richtig nicht gegen die krise
anzusparen sondern auch breite hilfen
und hohe investitionen möglich zu machen
so dass wir aus der krise heraus wachsen
meine damen und herren für den erfolg
der transformation es die höhe der
eingesetzten mittel aber nur die eine
seite
erfolgreich wird die transformation nur
sein wenn investitionen deutlich
schneller wirksam werden
darum werden wir innerhalb des ersten
jahres dieser bundesregierung ein
umfassendes paket zur planungs und
genehmigungsbescheid einigung vorliegen
unser ziel ist die dauer der verfahren
zu halbieren dafür werden wir die
personelle und technische ausstattung
der behörden und gerichte ausbauen das
wollen wir mit einem
beschleunigungsprogramm mit den ländern
angehen
große und besonders bedeutsame
infrastrukturmaßnahmen also etwa
wichtige bahnstrecken oder stromtrassen
werden wir per gesetz auf den weg
bringen und wir werden regelung treffen
die das verhältnis von klima und
artenschutz klären
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
klimaschutz wird in dieser
bundesregierung zu einer zentralen
querschnittsaufgabe und wir wollen uns
gemeinsam daran messen lassen wie
erfolgreich wird diese aufgabe lösen
schon im kommenden jahr werden wir ein
umfassendes sofortprogramm beschließen
dass unsere anstrengungen treibhausgase
zu verringern quer durch alle sektoren
verstärkt
wir werden die europäische kommission
aktiv dabei unterstützen ihr klimapaket
fifty five zu unter zu verwirklichen und
wir wollen gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen partnern die europäische
und die internationale klimapolitik
voranbringen wir werden auch unsere
internationalen bemühungen für den
klimaschutz erhöhen wir sind dem pariser
klima abkommen verpflichtet und werden
zu seinen erfolg beitragen
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig werden wir zusammen mit
unseren partnern die gründung eines
offenen klima clubs voranbringen der
sich auf gemeinsame standards
verständigt und deutsche unternehmen im
internationalen wettbewerb von kabeln
dicke geschützt
meine damen und herren der wohlstand
unseres landes hängt an unserer
fähigkeit die infrastrukturen für das
klimaneutrale zeitalter aufzubauen bei
der energieversorgung wird das besonders
deutlich
im kommenden jahr beenden wir das
zeitalter der atomkraft in deutschland
nach jahrzehnten des gesellschaftlichen
konflikten
gleichzeitig arbeiten wir am zügigen
ausstieg aus der kohleverstromung
idealerweise schon im jahre 2030
es hat ja um das wort idealerweise
debatten gegeben es bedeutet aber ganz
einfach voraussetzung eines vorgezogenen
ausstieg ist versorgungssicherheit
voraussetzung ist dass wir einen großen
teil unseres strombedarfs aus windkraft
und voll trüber tag decken können dass
wir neue gaskraftwerke bauen und diese
baldmöglichst mit wasserstoff betreiben
können meine damen und herren heute
liegt der strombedarf in deutschland bei
560 terawattstunden wir rechnen damit
dass er im jahr 2030 zwischen 680 bis
750 terawattstunden betragen wird wir
müssen also mindestens
120 terawatt stunden zusätzlich decken
dass es ungefähr der heutige strombedarf
der niederlande ein land mit fast 18
millionen einwohnern
80 prozent unseres strombedarfs sollen
bis 2010 erneuert
die trägern gedeckt werden das bedeutet
wir müssen die produktion von
erneuerbaren strom bis 230 mehr als
verdoppeln ja
das ist eine gigantische aufgabe
aber ich bin der festen überzeugung
das wird uns gelingen
auf die grundlagen haben wir uns
verständigt schon im kommenden jahr
werden wir würden und hemmnisse
beseitigen und ist nur zwei prozent der
fläche in deutschland für die windkraft
reserviert werden
photovoltaik module sollen auf deutschen
dächern zur regel werden bei
gewerblichen neubauten werden sie
verbindlich vorgeschrieben wir werden
den ausbau unserer offshore wind
kapazitäten voranbringt und mit unseren
nordsee partnern stärker kooperieren wir
fördern den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien aber wir fordern auch auf dauer
müssen sich die erneuerbaren energien
auf dem markt finanzieren darum werden
wir den förderverein zukauf stärken wenn
der kohleausstieg vollendet ist muss
auch die förderung der erneuerbaren
energien auslaufen
frau präsidentin ein zentraler pfeiler
unser klima politik ist die
verkehrswende
dass die bürgerinnen bürger heute
deutlich mobiler sind als vor 30 50 oder
100 jahren ist eine große errungenschaft
mobilität erweitert den horizont
ermöglicht teilhabe begegnung und
lebenschancen
wir werden in den kommenden jahren dafür
sorgen dass mobilität einfacher
komfortabler und klimafreundlicher wird
und dabei für alle bezahlbar bleibt
unser schwerpunkt wird auf dem ausbau
der schiene lieben wir werden die
großstädte besser an den fernverkehr
anbinden und das europäische nacht zum
netzausbau wir werden die bahn wieder
stärker im ländlichen raum verankern und
wo es sinnvoll ist stillgelegte trassen
reaktivieren
wir wollen den anteil des
schienengüterverkehrs bis 230 deutlich
erhöhen und die fahrgastzahlen
personenverkehr deutlich steigern dafür
werden wir in den kommenden jahren die
schienenwege ausbauen und wird digitaler
technik ausstatten und wir werden das
finanzielle engagement des bundes für
den nahverkehr noch einmal steigern mit
den ländern und kommunen werden ausbau
und modernisierungs pakt für einen
besseren öpnv ausschließen
gleichzeitig wollen wir die
nutzerfreundlichkeit über die
verschiedenen verkehrsverbünde hinweg
erhöhen zb durch gemeinsame
qualitätsstandards und eine klarere
tarifstruktur zugleich wissen wir für
viele bürgerinnen und bürger wird das
auto weiter und verzichtbar sein viele
fahnen gern im auto und das soll auch so
bleiben
aber die antriebe müssen klimafreundlich
werden nach mageren jahren hat sich die
elektromobilität zu einer
erfolgsgeschichte entwickelt wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie weiter tempo
aufnimmt
viele hersteller haben ehrgeizige pläne
ihre produktion auf klimafreundliche
antriebe umzustellen mit dem ausbau der
heimischen batteriezellen fertigung
werden wir dafür sorgen dass ein hoher
teil der wertschöpfung rund ums
automobil in deutschland bleibt wir
werden die staatliche förderung für 2022
fortschreiben und danach schrittweise
abbauen und gerade im bereich der plug
in hybride stärker an der elektrischen
fahrleistung ausrichten unser ziel ist
dass im jahre 2030 in deutschland 15
millionen elektroautos unterwegs sind
der schlüssel hierfür liegt in der
ladeinfrastruktur
laden muss so einfach werden wie tanken
das angebot an ladesäulen muss den
bedarf zunächst vorausgehen die
förderung für den ausbau der
ladeinfrastruktur werden wir effektiver
und effizienter ausgestrahlten hemmnisse
in genehmigungsprozessen bei
netzinfrastrukturen netzanschluss
bedingungen werden wir abbauen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
in staat und gesellschaft streben wir
einen digitalen aufbruch an dazu gehört
zunächst für alle wichtig und erfahrbar
die digitale infrastruktur
unser ziel ist die flächendeckende
versorgung mit glasfaser und dem
neuesten mobilfunkstandard wir werden
besonders dort investieren wo der
nachholbedarf am größten ist um
funklöcher zu schließen deutschland muss
als technologiestandort wieder an die
spitze kommen
darum werden wir investitionen dem
künstlichen intelligenz und quanten
technologien im cyber sicherheit robotik
und weitere zukunftstechnologien stärken
und wir wollen auch die
halbleiterproduktion ausbauen
auch die digitalisierung der verwaltung
werden wir entschieden vorantreiben von
den einheitlichen digitalen lösungen für
bund und länder arbeiten
in europa werden wir uns dafür einsetzen
dass die datenschutzbestimmungen der
datenschutz grund verordnung besser und
einheitlicher durchgesetzt werden wir
brauchen aber auch ambitioniertere
regelungen für einen fairen wettbewerb
in der digitalwirtschaft das
bundeskartellamt werden wir im umgang
mit plattformen deshalb starten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
lösen werden wir alle dieser großen
aufgaben nur wenn alle bürger und bürger
in deutschland kommen können und das hat
voraussetzungen
eine davon ist die anhebung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro
das sollte im laufe des kommenden jahres
geschehen der bundesarbeitsminister wird
dafür zeitnah einen gesetzentwurf auf
den weg bringen
der gesetzliche mindestlohn wurde schon
vor sechs jahren eingeführt er lag zu
beginn bei 8 euro 50 die erfahrungen
sind positiv viele arbeitnehmer und
arbeitnehmer haben profitiert die
warnung vor geschäftsaufgaben und
entlassungen waren unbegründet
das mindestlohngesetz sieht die
regelmäßige anpassung durch eine
unabhängige kommission vor diese
regelung werden wir beibehalten
und doch werden wir einen einmaligen
antreffen schritt des gesetzgebers
vornehmen das ist in einem reichen
wirtschaftlich starken land wie unser
möglich und das ist auch nötig meine
damen und herren
bis zu zehn millionen erwerbstätige
werden davon profitieren und ihren
lebensunterhalt besser bestreiten können
es ist der ganz konkrete ausdruck einer
politik des respekts dasselbe gilt für
die gleichstellung von frauen und
männern die muss in diesem jahrzehnt in
unserem land endlich realität werden und
nicht erst in irgend einer fernen
zukunft
weltliche gleich lang bedeutete über den
gleichen einfluss die gleiche macht und
die gleichen möglichkeiten zu verfügen
gleichstellung bedeutet auch für gleiche
arbeit muss gleicher lohn gezahlt werden
dazu werden wir die möglichkeiten
ausbauen die das entgelt
transparenzgesetz bietet meine damen und
herren
respekt vor leistung heißt auch respekt
vor lebensleistung das bedeutet im alter
nach einem langen berufsleben eine
angemessene rente zu erhalten
wir wissen um die herausforderung in
einer älter werdenden gesellschaft ein
hohes niveau sozialer sicherheit zu
garantieren und zugleich das system
bezahlbar zu halten
darum sichern wir das mindest
rentenniveau bei 48 prozent
wir sehen auch keine weitere anhebung
der regelaltersgrenze vor
und zugleich werden wir den
nachholfaktor wieder gelten lassen und
bauen denn die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung an die teilweise
kapitaldeckung ein
aus dem haushalt werden der
rentenversicherungen kommenden jahr
zunächst zehn milliarden euro zugeführt
die rentabel angelegt werden können und
als demokrat pires erwitter dienen
wichtig ist uns auch dass möglichst
viele arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer
anspruch auf eine betriebsrente haben
und eine weitere aufgabe in dieser
legislaturperiode wird es sein in zeiten
der anhaltenden niedrigzinsen bessere
angebote in der dritten säule der
privaten altersvorsorge zu entwickeln
gerade für solche die staatlich
gefördert werden
alle selbstständigen sofern sie nicht in
versorgungswerken abgesichert sind oder
eine entsprechende private
altersvorsorge aufbauen werden in
zukunft gesetzlich versichert sein der
mit einer etwaigen armut im alter
vorgebeugt
meine damen und herren auch unser
gesundheitsversorgung und unser
pflegesystem müssen den
herausforderungen der zukunft gerecht
werden was besser werden muss haben wir
gerade auch in der pandemie erlebt wir
brauchen heimische kapazitäten der
medizinischen produktion um nicht wieder
in abhängigkeit zu geraten
wir werden den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst besser ausstatten und
das medizinische personal
konkurrenzfähiger bezahlen
wir werden die chancen der
digitalisierung auch im
gesundheitssystem heben wir werden die
ambulante versorgung verbessern die
krankenhausplanung und finanzierung
reformieren
meine damen und herren
die pflegekräfte die frauen und männer
in der pflege haben großartiges
geleistet oft über das erträgliche
hinaus ihnen gilt unser dank
wir haben deshalb ein pflege bonus
vereinbart und werden die
steuerbefreiung anheben doch wir wissen
dass das noch keine strukturelle lösung
ist darum werden wir die
arbeitsbedingungen der pflegekräfte
verbessern indem wir eine bessere
personalausstattung in krankenhäusern
möglich machen werden
richtig ist auch dass wir die lücke
zwischen den löhnen der kranken und
altenpflege schließen den bürgern und
bürger pflegebedürftig werden ist das
für sie und ihre angehörigen oft
finanziell überfordern darum werden wir
die eigenanteile der kosten der pflege
ein begrenzen
und meine damen und herren wir werden
prüfen wie eine freiwillig wählbare
pflege vollversicherung im alltag für
alle pflegekosten die
zusätzlich anfangen aufkommen kann
meine damen und herren dreh und
angelpunkt für die zukunft der sozialen
sicherung bleibt der arbeitsmarkt
darum ist es wichtig dass wir ein
weiterhin hohes und möglichst noch
steigen das beschäftigungsniveau in
deutschland haben am besten mit
sozialpartnerschaft mit tarifbindung und
mitbestimmung gerade in zeiten des
wandels brauchen wir starke
gewerkschaften und starke
arbeitgeberverbände
ein hohes beschäftigungsniveau ist auch
aus gesellschaftlichen und
wirtschaftlichen gründen nötig wir
werden die situation in der pflege
nachhaltig und
nur dann verbessern wenn mehr
pflegekräfte dort tätig sein können wir
werden viele unser vorhaben vom
wohnungsbau bis zur energiewende nur
dann hinbekommen wenn ausreichend
qualifizierte fachkräfte im einsatz sind
für eine bessere pflege für den bau von
wohnungen für die industrielle
transformation für innovative
unternehmen überall brauchen wir
qualifizierte arbeitskräfte
das ist im übrigen ein fast schon
symbolhaftes projekt der neuen
fortschritts regierung weil wir hier
wirtschaftliche ziele mit sozialen und
gesellschaftspolitischen zielen
verbinden und wir müssen daher auch für
gute aus und weiterbildung
das ist mir auch persönlich sehr wichtig
denn auch dabei geht es wieder um
respekt ich will dass eine berufliche
ausbildung im dualen system in
deutschland genauso viel anerkennung
erhält wie das studium
erfahrungen sollen alle jugendlichen die
einen ausbildungsplatz suchen auf einen
ausbildungsplatz bekommen damit das
klappt haben wir eine
ausbildungsgarantie
vereinbart
für viele junge leute die sich aber für
ein studium entscheiden werden wir die
ausbildungsförderung verbessern vor 50
jahren wurde das bafög eingeführt es war
eine errungenschaft für mehr
chancengleichheit wir werden das bafög
eltern unabhängiger machen die geplante
kindergrundsicherung
gerade kinder grundsicherung ist eine
basisfinanzierung für studien denn wir
werden zugleich die freibeträge und die
altersgrenzen anheben damit mehr
studierende zugang zum bafög bekommen
und wir werden prüfen ob wir den
darlehensanteil senken können
zugleich
zugleich endet die berufliche bildung
nicht mit der erst ausbildung erst recht
nicht angesichts der transformation die
wir schon jetzt erleben und in den
nächsten jahrzehnten noch erleben werden
die welt wird digitaler wir müssen
klimaneutral werden viele tätigkeiten
können von robotern und künstlicher
intelligenz erledigt werden aber bei
weitem nicht alle die arbeit da bin ich
sicher wird uns nicht ausgehen aber die
tätigkeiten und aufgaben werden sich
verändern berufliche weiterbildung wird
immer wichtiger
darum verbessern wir das aufstiegs bafög
für diejenigen die sich für diesen weg
entscheiden mit höheren fördersätzen und
freibeträgen sorgen wir dafür dass auch
eine zweite vollqualifizierende
ausbildung und möglich ist auch die
augen arbeitsförderung richten wir
stärker auf weiterbildung aus mit einer
bildungs zeit und ein qualifizierungs
geld das sich am kurzarbeitergeld
orientiert klar ist ebenfalls dass wir
in deutschland deutlich mehr
arbeitskräfte brauchen darum werden wir
unser einwanderungsrecht modernisieren
und ergänzen auf der basis eines neuen
punktesystems erleichtern wir
ausländischen arbeitskräften die
jobsuche in deutschland gleichzeitig
steuern wir damit gezielt den zugang zum
deutschen arbeitsmarkt das ist ein
fortschritt gelaufen
und wichtig ist deshalb auch dass wir
bildungs und berufsabschlüsse aus dem
ausland leichter und schneller
anerkennen
meine damen und herren mehr förderung
wollen wir auch in der grundsicherung es
ist gut dass wir ein sozialsystem mit
einer grundsicherung haben für alle die
nicht oder die nicht mehr über andere
systeme abgesichert sind aber besser ist
es wenn eine grundsicherung nicht oder
zumindest nicht lange in anspruch
genommen werden muss
was im volksmund hartz 4 heißt ersetzen
wir durch ein neues bürgergeld
es hat sich in der pandemie bewährt in
den ersten beiden jahren das vermögen
stärker zu schonen und die
angemessenheit der wohnung nicht zu
überprüfen das ist fair und entlastet
die betroffenen die
eingliederungsvereinbarung
ersetzen wir durch eine teilhabe
vereinbarung wir verzichten nicht auf
mitwirkungspflichten aber wir
verschaffen den vorrang ab dass man sich
nicht gleich qualifizieren kann wenn das
gut ist da zum beispiel einen
qualifizierten beruf gelernt hat und in
die grundsicherung rutscht sollte die
chance haben sich weiterzubilden oder
einen neuen beruf zu erlernen
das ist respekt vor dem beruf und der
lebensleistung
es bleibt beim prinzip fördern und
fordern aber wir fördern mehr und wir
fördern besser als bisher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir wollen frauen und wenn dann
gleichermaßen eine gute beschäftigung
biografie ermöglichen und zugleich den
fachkräftebedarf sichern das geht wenn
wir beruf und familie noch besser
vereinbar machen
das elterngeld ist ein erfolgsmodell
und wir wollen es noch besser machen es
soll sich lohnen wenn eltern die zeit
für erziehung pflege und erwerbsarbeit
partnerschaftlich teilen dazu gehört
dass der partner oder die
partner nach der geburt zwei wochen zeit
bekommt für die familie da zu sein ohne
den urlaub anzutasten wir sprechen von
einer vergüteten freistellung und es
geht uns darum gleichzeitig die kinder
krankentage dauerhaft anzuheben das
alles hilft familien
eine große und technisch anspruchsvolle
reformen nehmen wir uns vor mit der
einführung einer neuen
kindergrundsicherung
derzeit haben wir noch verschiedene
leistungen und steuerliche regelungen
die nebeneinander existieren das ist zu
kompliziert nicht gut verständlich und
in vielen fällen auch nicht
bedarfsgerecht die kindergrundsicherung
die wir im laufe dieser
legislaturperiode einführen werden wird
aus einem sockelbetrag für jedes kind
bestehen sowie als ein zusatzbetrag der
vom einkommen der eltern abhängt die
kindergrundsicherung wird unbürokratisch
digital zu erhalten seien ein großer
fortschritt zu einem modernen
sozialstaat
gemeinsam mit den ländern werden wir die
frühkindliche bildung in den kitas
stärken bessere startchancen in sozial
benachteiligten schulen schaffen
schulischen ganztagsangebote verbessern
und mit dem digital packt 20 die
digitalisierung unserer schulen
vorantreiben
einige sehr großen sozialen fragen
unserer zeit ist das wohl
guter bezahlbarer wohnraum ist ein
menschliches grundbedürfnis aber für
viele bürgerinnen und bürger gibt es
heute gerade in unseren städten zu wenig
bezahlbare wohnung sie müssen endlos
suchen
finanziellen an ihre grenzen gehen oder
lange pendelt wege zur arbeit in kauf
nehmen der traum vom häuschen am
stadtrand oder der eigenen funktionen im
kiez bleibt für normal verdienende
familien immer öfter unerfüllt
die lage auf dem wohnungsmarkt erfordert
dass die neue bundesregierung
entschlossen handelt und das tun wir wir
schaffen ein neues ministerium für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
damit wir alle kraft auf diese aufgabe
konzentrieren kann
wir wollen dass in deutschland pro jahr
400.000 neue wohnungen gebaut werden
darunter 100.000 öffentlich geförderte
wir werden ein bündnis für bezahlbaren
wohnraum einberufen zusammen mit den
ländern und kommunen der bauern
wohnungswirtschaft sowie den
mieterverbänden werden wir beraten wie
wir schneller und günstiger wäre wohl
brauchen in deutschland schaffen
das missverhältnis von angebot und
nachfrage auf dem wohnungsmarkt kann
aber nicht von heute auf morgen
ausgeglichen werden darum werden wir
auch in der zwischenzeit etwas tun um
den anstieg der mieten in grenzen zu
halten wir verlängern die bestehende
mietpreis bremse bis zum jahr 2029 und
wir senken den angespannten
wohnungsmärkten die kappungsgrenze in
drei jahren darf die miete dann um nicht
mehr als elf prozent steigen wenn sie
noch unterhalb der ortsüblichen
vergleichsmiete liegt mehr fairness
zwischen vermietern und mietern setzen
wir auch durch beim klimaschutz auch für
das heizen mit fossilen energien gibt es
ja bereits den co2 preis dieser dient
aber dazu dass auf klimafreundliches
heizen umgerüstet wird
mittelfristig wollen wir eine teil war
mitte einführen die grundversorgung wird
teil der miete alles darüber hinaus zeit
der mieter so besteht für beide seiten
der anreiz zum umrüsten und
energiesparen und jetzt in der
übergangszeit wollen wir im kommenden
jahr eine differenzierte kostenteilung
durchsetzen das ist gerecht
meine damen und herren die
transformation die jetzt vor uns liegt
wird auf dauer nur erfolgreich sein wenn
sie von einer breiten mehrheit der
bürgerinnen bürger in unserem land
getragen wird
darum werden wir die kohle regionen in
ostdeutschland und nordrhein westfalen
weiterhin solidarisch unterstützen unser
versprechen gilt niemand wird ins
bergfreie fallen die folgen des
strukturwandels bewältigen wir gemeinsam
das gilt auch im hinblick auf die großen
veränderungen in der industrie insgesamt
wir werden eine vorausschauende
strukturpolitik betreiben gezielt neue
wertschöpfung schaffen zb beim
wasserstoff oder der batteriezellen
fertigung und wir werden den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern zur
seite stehen gerade in zeiten steigender
energiepreise werden wir darauf achten
dass energie kein luxusgut wird nicht
für unternehmen in unserem land und
nicht für die bürgerinnen und bürger
richtig ist langfristig wird fossile
energie auf berechenbare weise teurer
dass sarah bei menschen mit kleinem
geldbeutel nicht überfordern eine warme
wohnung ist ein grundrecht die fahrt mit
dem auto zur arbeit oder zum supermarkt
ist für viele schlichtweg notwendig
gute klima politik fordert nicht
verzicht sondern sie ermöglicht den
umstieg auf klimafreundliche
alternativen
und vor allem deshalb werden wir private
haushalte unternehmen schon im jahr 2023
von der eeg-umlage befreien und diese
zukünftig aus dem bundeshaushalt
refinanzieren
das entlastet eine vierköpfige familie
pro jahr im vergleich zu 221 um rund 300
euro und s reduziert den bürokratischen
aufwand für unternehmen und staat der
den vergangenen 20 jahren rund um die
eeg umlage entstanden ist so entsteht
auch ein neuer rückenwind für den
umstieg auf e autos und wärmepumpen der
co2 preis fahrt bleibt stabil deshalb
haben wir uns darauf verständigt dass
die benzin öl und gas nicht zusätzlich
verteuern wir werden außerdem das
wohngeld modernisieren eine
klimakomponente einführen und dann
einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger zahlen
auch an anderer stelle sorgen wir dafür
dass die bürgerinnen bürger mehr geld
zur verfügung karten
so werden wir die bedingungen für midi
jobs verbessern indem wir die
verdienstgrenze auf bis zu 1600 euro
erhöhen dadurch profitieren mehr
beschäftigte von den reduzierten
sozialbeiträgen und
wir erhöhen die anreize für derzeitige
mieter ihre arbeitszeit in richtung
einer vollzeitstelle weiter zu erhöhen
mit erhöhung des mindestlohns sehen wir
auch die grenze für mini-jobs auf 520
euro an
das urteil des bundesfinanzhofs zur
rentenbesteuerung werden wir rasch
umsetzen nicht erst 225 sonne schob
schon ab dem übernächsten jahr werden
die beiträge zur rentenversicherung als
sonderausgabe voll abzugsfähig sein das
ist eine steuerentlastung für millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger
zudem werden wir den steuerpflichtigen
teil der ausgezahlten renten langsamer
ansteigen lassen als bisher im gesetz
vorgesehen das ist eine steuerentlastung
für viele künftige rentnerinnen und
rentner
meine damen und herren
heute ist deutschland ein land von
ungeheurer innere vielfalt die
bundesregierung begreift diese
gesellschaftliche vielfalt als eine der
großen stärken unseres landes
sie verwechselt zusammenhalt nicht mit
homogenität sondern sie schafft die
rahmenbedingungen dafür dass
zusammenhalt aus der vielfalt heraus
möglich ist sie schützt die sicherheit
der bürgerinnen bürger und schafft die
voraussetzung für eine gesellschaft des
respekts zum demokratischen gemeinwesen
gehört ein handlungsfähiger rechtsstaat
der freiheit und sicherheit garantiert
wer bei der polizei oder beim zoll bei
sicherheitsbehörden oder ordnungsämtern
arbeitet verdient unseren respekt meine
damen und herren
die arbeit ist oft hart und die aufgaben
werden immer umfangreicher gerade jetzt
etwa bei der durchsetzung der
notwendigen auflagen zur bekämpfung der
korona pandemie im namen der gesamten
bundesregierung danke ich allen die tag
und nacht auf der straße und in
schwierigen situationen die sicherheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger und die
ordnung unseres gemeinwesens
gewährleisten
aber auch diese anerkennung muss hand
und zusammen darum werden wir für die
gute personal und sachausstattung der
bundespolizei sorgen und diese als
dienstherr attraktiver machen
die schwerpunkte der arbeit der
sicherheitsbehörden in den nächsten
jahren werden auf den kampf gegen
extremismus und organisiert ihre
organisierte kriminalität gelegt werden
dazu gehören prävention die
radikalisierung und gefahrenabwehr und
ausdrücklich teile ich die einschätzung
der bundesinnenminister die größte
bedrohung für unsere demokratie ist der
rechtsextremismus darum werden wir diese
gefahren
wurden konzepte für demokratie fördern
für die stärkung der
zivilgesellschaftlichen beratung und für
präventionsangebote werden wir jetzt
nutzen und ein demokratie fördergesetz
auf den weg bringen
wir werden entschieden gegen
organisierte kriminalität in jeder form
vorgehen das effektivste mittel dafür
besteht darin diesen strukturen den
geldhahn abzudrehen
darum werden wir die
geldwäschebekämpfung stärken immobilien
werden künftig nicht mehr mit bargeld
bezahlt werden kann
der pakt für den rechts den pakt für den
rechtsstaat werden wir verstetigen und
um einen digital pakt für die justiz
weiter wer braucht schnelle und
effiziente gerichtsverfahren
gerichtsverhandlung sollen deshalb auch
online geführt werden können und wir
werden sicher stehen schön dass täter
vom hass und hetze im netz identifiziert
und strafrechtlich belangt werden
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
ein einwanderungsland
darum ist es höchste zeit dass wir uns
auch als einwanderungs und
integrationsgesetz schafft begreifen
dazu gehört dass wir
den weg zur deutschen
staatsangehörigkeit erleichtern so so
ermöglichen wir
nur so ermöglichen wir volle politische
teilhabe und damit bessere integration
ein bohrer werde künftig in der regel
bereits nach fünf jahren aufenthalt in
deutschland möglichst lang
und wir werden die mehrfach
staatsangehörigkeit ermöglichen es
entspricht der lebenswirklichkeit vieler
eingewandert in unserem land dass sie
ihre herkunft identität in rechtlicher
hinsicht auch nach der einführung habe
halten können
mit dem bekenntnis zur
einwanderungsgesellschaft geht einher
dass wir viel stärker als bisher
repräsentanz möglich machen werden das
gilt gerade in der öffentlichen
verwaltung darum werden wir ein
partizipations gesetz vorlegen und
diesen anforderungen besser gerecht zu
werden
wir werden eine vernunft geleitete
migrationspolitik betreiben die legale
migration befördert und irreguläre
migration reduziert dazu gehören zügige
asylverfahren sowie gute perspektiven
für diejenigen die in deutschland gut
integriert sind dazu gehört aber auch
die konsequente rückführung besonders im
fall von straftätern und gefährdet
meine damen und herren nicht selten war
unsere gesellschaft in den vergangenen
jahren moderner als staat und regierung
längst überfällig ist daher die
nachholende modernisierung die diese
bundesregierung auf den gebieten der
gleichstellung der körperlichen
selbstbestimmung zu dem familienrecht
auf den weg bringen wird
wir werden dafür sorgen dass unser
familienrecht unser personenstand zum
strafrecht in der gelebten wirklichkeit
ankommt
wir werden das institut der
verantwortungsgemeinschaft einführen und
das adoptionsrecht reformieren
das transsexuellengesetz werden wir
durch eine selbstbestimmung der gesetz
ersetzen
wir wollen dass ärzte und ärzte
öffentliche informationen über
schwangerschafts abbrüche bereitstellen
können ohne eine straftat vorliegt
daher werden wir den paragrafen 219 aus
dem strafgesetzbuch streichen
und wir sind uns einig wir werden den
gleichbehandlungs artikel 3 des
grundgesetzes um ein verbot der
diskriminierung wegen sexueller
identität ergänzen
und wir werden die grefrather im
grundgesetz ersetzen
meine damen und herren im kulturellen
leben liegen die fundamente auf denen
unser zusammenleben gegründet ist in
ihrer ganzen vielfalt fördert kulturelle
und künstlerische impulse den aufbruch
in unserer gesellschaft jetzt braucht
der kampf gegen die pandemie hat es
nötig gemacht entscheidungen zu treffen
die genau dieses kulturelle leben
besonders hart getroffen haben um so
mehr wird sich die neue bundesregierung
darum kümmern die soziale lage der
künstlerinnen und kreativen zu
verbessern und das kulturelle leben in
unserem land zu einer neuen blüte zu
führen
meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung bekennt sich zur
europäischen einigung sie wird aber auch
hier nicht bei bekenntnissen stehen
bleiben das gelingen europas ist unser
wichtigstes nationales anliegen
europas einigung wurde betrieben mit dem
ziel des ausgleichs zwischen früheren
feiern sie gründet auf den erfahrungen
der düstersten kapitel unserer
gemeinsamen geschichte in denen unser
land so viel leid über europa und die
welt gebracht hat
diese zentrale mission der europäischen
union die wahrung des inneren friedens
europas hat nichts an ihrer aktualität
verloren
nehmen wir dieses kostbare gut welches
mutige frauen und männer über jahrzehnte
aufgebaut haben niemals als gegeben es
bedarf unseres andauernden engagement
aber dabei dürfen wir nicht stehen
bleiben worum geht es heute
wollen wir in einer welt von zehn
milliarden menschen noch vorkommt wollen
wir gehört werden wollen wir nicht zum
spielball fremder mächte werden und
wollen wir unseren europäischen way of
life selbstbewusst verteidigen dann geht
das nur gemeinsam als europäische union
zusammenhalt und souveränität das ist
die aufgabe für europa für das gelingen
des souveränen europas trägt unser land
eine besondere verantwortung nicht nur
wegen unserer geschichte als größte
volkswirtschaft im zentrum unseres
kontinents mit einer geschichte von
teilung und wiedervereinigung können wir
nicht kommentieren dann rand stehen das
instrument unserer europapolitik darf
nicht die schnelle innenpolitische
schlagzeile sein es muss in der
beharrlichen bereitschaft bestehen
brücken zu bauen durch beständiges
engagement und verhandlungen so haben es
meine vorgängerin und meine vorgänger
gehalten und das wird auch mein handeln
leiten
die europafreundliche ausrichtung aller
demokratischen parteien in diesem haus
ist keine selbstverständlichkeit sie ist
ein schatz bei allen differenzen in der
sache lassen sie uns diesen schatz
bewahren
zu recht erwarten die bürgerinnen und
bürger das europa handlungsfähiger wird
wir wollen hier für die möglichkeiten
des lissabonner vertrags nutzen es muss
zur regel werden dass wir in europa mit
qualifizierter mehrheit entscheiden
können im rat auch auf den gebieten wo
das heute nicht der fall ist das ist
kein verlust das ist ein gewinn und
souveränität
und wir müssen auch immer bereit seinen
gruppen von staaten lösung
auszuprobieren wenn noch nicht alle so
weit sind so wie wir es bereits bei
cheng gemacht haben beim euro oder auch
in der sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik
wir brauchen eine europäische politische
kultur eine kultur des konstruktiven
streits im sinne eines gemeinsamen rings
um den besten weg
respektvoll in anerkennung unserer sehr
unterschiedlichen geschichte der
vielfalt unserer politischen geografie
aber stets im bewusstsein all dessen was
uns als europäer verbindet
europapolitik ist das ist es doch allen
klar schon lange keine außenpolitik mehr
europäische politik betrifft längst den
alltag jeder einzelnen bürger und jedes
einzelnen bürgers europa politik ist zu
einem großen teil unserer innenpolitik
geworden
europa muss zusammenstehen jedes
europäische land hat seine nationalen
interessen die müssen sie nicht
verstecken aber alle und gerade wir
müssen kompromissfähig seien keine
auseinandersetzung darf dem zusammenhalt
europas oder zentrale errungenschaften
die offene grenzen zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten oder die gemeinsame
währung infrage stellen das europäische
wiederaufbauprogramm reaktionen auf die
korona krise ist beispielhaft für diese
neue einigkeit europas in stunden der
krise
wir wollen das nutzen in europa
resilient und zukunftsfähig zu machen
meine damen und herren europa ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie gegründet auf
freiheit menschenwürde demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
allen mitgliedstaaten
alle mitgliedsstaaten haben sich auf
diese werte verpflichtet als sie unsere
gemeinschaft beitragen die
bundesregierung bekennt sich zu diesen
werten und sie wird bei ihrer
verteidigung klar und eindeutig an der
seite der europäischen kommission als
der hüterin der verträge stehen
ich freue mich dass sich der
französische staatspräsident bei seiner
jüngsten rede im europäischen parlament
ausdrücklich auf unseren
koalitionsvertrag bezogen und
unterstützung für einige unserer
reformvorschläge bekundet hat
frankreich ist unser engster verbündeter
und die deutsch-französische
freundschaft das unverzichtbare
fundament der europäischen union die
bundesregierung
gibt keinen politischen vorstoß
unternehmen ohne ängste konsultation mit
unseren französischen freunden
die deutsch französische verständigung
ist die notwendige bedingung für
fortschritt in europa aber wissen auch
sie ist noch keine hinreichende
bedingung die zukunft europas wird weder
in paris noch in berlin entschieden
gerade unser land hat eine besondere
verantwortung auch die interessen der
östlichen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union und unsere
osteuropäischen nachbarn mitzudenken
gerade habe ich mit dem polnischen
ministerpräsidenten über die lage an der
grenze zu bilder russ gesprochen und ihm
unsere solidarität versichert
grenzen müssen unantastbar bleiben und
der zynische missbrauch von geflüchteten
für hybride attacken auf unserer
östlichen nachbarn muss aufhören das
werden wir beim europäischen rat morgen
noch einmal bekräftigen
wir blicken in diesen tagen auch mit
großer sorge auf die sicherheitslage an
der russisch-ukrainischen grenze wir
werden hier über beim europäischen rat
und beim heutigen gipfel der östlichen
partnerschaft intensiv beraten
aber lassen sie mich
sollten es noch nicht alle verstanden
haben hier wiederholen was meine
amtsvorgängerin gesagt hat jede
verletzung territorialer integrität wird
ihren preis einen hohen preis haben und
wir werden hier mit unseren europäischen
partnern und unseren transatlantischen
verbündeten mit einer stimme sprechen
gleichzeitig sind wir zum konstruktiven
dialog bereit vor dem hintergrund
unserer geschichte muss dies im
verhältnis zu russland gerade für unser
land geld
gerade wir müssen bereit sein immer
einmal öfter den versuch der
verständigung zu unternehmen den versuch
aus der eskalationsspirale auszubrechen
so wie es etwa mit dem normandie
princess zeitweilig gelungen ist das
darf aber nicht missverstanden werden
als eine neue deutsche ostpolitik
ostpolitik kann im vereinten europa nur
eine europäische aus politik sein
diese gründet auf den prinzipien des
völkerrechts und der europäischen
friedensordnung auf die sich auch
russland verpflichtet hat und die es mit
der annexion der krim so schwerwiegend
verletzt hat
wir werden uns als europäische union
nicht spalten lassen das gilt auch mit
blick auf länder deren systeme nicht
demokratisch sind etwa china mit seinem
rasanten aufstieg zur technologie und
militär macht und die chinesische
führung vertritt ihre interessen mit
großem selbstbewusstsein
deutschland und europa haben einen grund
unsere interessen ebenso selbstbewusst
und engagiert zu vertreten wir müssen
unsere china politik an dem china
ausrichten dass wir real vorfinden
das heißt aber nicht dass heißt aber
auch dass wir unsere augen nicht
verschließen vor der kritischen
menschenrechtslage und verstöße gegen
universum enormen beim namen nennen das
ändert nichts daran dass sein land von
der größe und geschichte chinas einen
zentralen platz im internationalen
konzert der völker hat deshalb bieten
wir china zusammenarbeit an bei
menschheits herausforderung wie der
klimakrise der pandemie oder der
rüstungskontrolle der bieten china einen
fairen wirtschaftlichen wettbewerb zum
beiderseitigen nutzen an mit gleichen
spielregeln für alle
deutschland und europa investieren in
unsere eigene politische wirtschaftliche
und technologische stärke wir nutzen die
stärke eines geeinten europas und des
binnenmarktes und für faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen für unsere
unternehmen einzutreten und auch global
den wettbewerb aufzunehmen
meine damen und herren unser wichtigster
partner hierbei sind die vereinigten
staaten mit präsident beiden eigentlich
die überzeugung dass die liberalen
demokratien der welt neu beweisen müssen
dass sie die besseren faireren und die
gerechteren antworten auf die
herausforderung des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts liefern können
das gilt für jedes einzelne land das
gilt aber für das verhältnis der länder
untereinander den multilateralismus ist
herausgefordert und muss sich neu
beweisen
deshalb wird die bundesregierung für die
multilaterale zusammenarbeit und ihre
institutionen sich immer stark machen
die deutsch amerikanische freundschaft
und die nato sind das unverzichtbare
fundament unserer sicherheit und
soldatinnen und soldaten leisten
unentbehrlichen beitrag zum schutz
unseres landes für frieden und
internationale sicherheit sie können
sich auf die bundesregierung und auf
dieses parlament verlassen
wir werden morgen auf dem europäischen
rat erstmals über ein neues
sicherheitspolitisches grundlagen
dokument sprechen dem sogenannten
strategischen compass deutschland wird
sich an dieser diskussion aktiv
beteiligen ebenso wie an der
überarbeitung des neuen strategischen
konzepts der nato dass auf dem gipfel im
nächsten jahr verabschiedet werden wird
wir werden investieren um die nato
fähigkeit ziele zu erreichen in enger
abstimmung mit unseren partnern für uns
ist wichtig europäische sicherheit und
transatlantische sicherheit gehen hand
in hand
deutschland unterstützt deshalb eine
neue eu nato erklärung die wir nun rasch
verabschieden wollen auch dazu wollen
wir uns beim europäischen rat beraten
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
zu beginn der 20er jahre unseres
jahrhunderts stehen wir vor großen
aufgaben und vor großen veränderungen
die bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem
land wissen das und ich habe eingangs
dieser rede die große frage zitiert dich
deshalb immer wieder gestellt bekommen
geht das alles gut aus für meine familie
für meine kinder für ganz normale leute
wie mich meine
antwort die antwort der bundesregierung
ist sehr klar ja das kann gut ausgehen
und ja das wird auch gut ausgeben wir
nehmen die herausforderung unserer zeit
an und wir sind zuversichtlich wir
werden sie bewältigen
nicht weil wir die probleme
unterschätzen sondern weil wir einen
präzisen plan dafür haben wie wir sie
lösen können und wie es gut werden kann
das moderne deutschland unser
deutschland ist ein starkes land wir
alle gemeinsam haben nicht den
geringsten grund uns vor der zukunft zu
fürchten
ganz im gegenteil
wenn wir zusammenhalten in einer
solidarischen gesellschaft des respekts
wenn wir uns ehrgeizige ziele setzen und
dem fortschritt die richtige richtung
geben wenn wir den aufbruch jetzt
entschlossen beginnen
dann werden wir nicht nur die korona
pandemie hinter uns lassen dann werden
wir in deutschland auch gemeinsam
erfolgreich sein und dann werden die
bürgerinnen und bürger am ende dieses
jahrzehnts sagen ja es geht gut aus es
geht gut aus für mich es geht gut aus
für meine familie und für unser land das
ist das ziel dieser bundesregierung
dafür arbeiten wir mit all unserer kraft
und mit dieser arbeit fangen wir jetzt
an vielen dank
und daher heben sich die abgeordneten
aus den regierungstragende fraktionen
für den neun deutschen bundeskanzler
olaf scholz der hier in 84 minuten noch
einmal die politik für die kommenden
jahre skizziert hat zuversicht
zusammenhalt gemeinschaft das könnte man
über diese rede schreiben und olaf
scholz jedenfalls hätten aber darauf
hingewiesen dass man jetzt handeln müsse
mehr fortschritt wagen müsste es gehe um
die zukunft und die arbeitsplätze in
deutschland